hey y'all um it's Corey and I'm finally
ready I know a lot of you um were
probably cringing that I gave him
another
chance um like where does a post wall
single mother for have the audacity to
say that she's giving him another I wish
I could talk to this guy look it she
will not behave until you say no and
walk away she won't do it you can't
negotiate with terrorists guys you can't
what up guys welcome to the just perly
things YouTube channel and welcome
welcome to my reaction series before I
start make sure you like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and ring that notification Bell today I
am going to be reacting to a woman who
can't stop crying after instantly
regretting divorcing her husband but
before I do make sure you guys sign up
for our email list guys as you know I
just had a Clips channel that was
deleted out of the blue I have been
demonetized out of the blue I don't know
how long I will be allowed on this
platform so please please please make
sure that you sign up for our Google
form and put your email and your phone
number in we're we going to be launching
a website soon with our own platform and
I would really like to see all you of
you guys on it so okay so we are going
to watch a woman who can't stop crying
these are papers for her for these
little pieces of paper little flimsy
pieces of
paper can break and end something that's
so strong in somebody's
heart I did
it
all right ladies we got to stop doing
this we got to stop doing this this is
real these are real tears they are
liquid chances are you have been here
before the chaos in the markets oil and
stocks just when you thought it was safe
and interest rates were Rising new
threats come out of nowhere tensions are
boiling from Asia to Europe and
adaptation is the key here to
safeguarding your wealth you may not
have considered gold before and it's not
speculation but insurance and right now
you need some insurance Noble gold
Investments has been protecting
investors from disaster for years with
precious metals so if you're worried it
might be time to take a fresh look at
gold and silver gold is a proven Safe
Haven shield for your portfolio and a
volatility balance against uncertainty
if it helps Noble gold Investments is
offering a free 3o silver America virtue
coin with its new IAS this month if you
open up your Noble gold Investments IAS
or 401 P roll over you can claim your
coin today remember crisis Cruise
portfolio's waiver and gold insulate
secure yourself against all threats go
to noblegold investments.com now that's
noblegold investments.com the only gold
company that I
[Music]
trust welcome back family today we are
reviewing This Modern woman who tried to
test her husband by divorcing him
thinking that he will beg her to not
leave him it all backfired when her
husband got so tired tired of her
childish behavior and didn't contest the
divorce now she cannot stop crying and
yeah I don't know why you guys break up
with your you break up marriages as a
game why everyone for her Reckless
actions let's first start by exposing
the day she was getting ready to file so
here's
this these are uh peers I just want to
point out she doesn't have heavy makeup
but big hoop earrings Botox forehead
it's just you just kind of look for
signals women that tend to invest a lot
in their appearance tend to divorce
their husbands because they're so
[Music]
self-centered now I I actually do think
image is important image matters but at
a certain point the image of your family
is more important than the image of
yourself and so many women want the
latest Botox treatment rather than I
don't know money for your children
College fun what you spend your money on
does say a lot about you and it's funny
cuz when I was younger I'm not going to
act like I never looked into any of this
stuff I just always thought it would be
better to spend my money on like guitar
lessons piano lessons that's just kind
of what now I can play guitar yeah and
piano a little bit a little bit I'm not
as good and
um that's very sad I don't understand
how eight
years of try my best to love somebody
and fight for
them and put up with so much abuse she's
the problem yeah and just be wiped out
with little
papers so
easy nails done and as much as I know
that this needs to happen
um it still hurts yeah this is so many
times chicks like it's like they're the
star of a movie like they think their
lives are just like movies this needs
why does it need to happen why and I bet
she filed cuz I never wanted this I
actually did love him and then she
wanted him to change and behave in a way
that she deemed acceptable maybe she
doesn't have the Botox forehead actually
and I know you how can you love somebody
that does those things to you I I don't
know I don't know why maybe I see
Brokenness in people and
I know and also like there's no right
wrong way to well okay there's there's
no so many times as women we try to
control men's behavior under the guise
of wanting to be loved right and what we
typically do is we will say oh I just
want you to love me and unfortunately
ladies we have negative qualities that
cannot be loved and as we expect men to
adapt to us and be the things that we
want to date but we don't think we have
to adapt to men and be the things that
they want to date I don't care I don't
care
what they
may we be better people and heal if we
want to Healing healing life is long
we're going to live to be 80 I'm sad
because
this this is the dreams that I had for
us as a family
and as husband and wife
and these little pieces of paper little
flimsy pieces of paper
can break and end something that's so
strong in somebody's
heart and it's
hard I'll get through but I'm sharing my
journey with you guys every part Journey
equals I just want to live in a movie
Just so you know that you're not alone
and you guys make me feel not alone so
I'm not alone because of you guys I have
replaced my family with Tik Tok here it
goes no ma'am no no body is forcing you
to file those papers you are willingly
deciding to divorce your husband this is
a lifechanging decision that you are
making in real time a nice house too
looks like a nice you know have to
assume the consequences guys this woman
thought that her husband was going to
beg her to stay and accept all her needy
demands if she threatened to file for
divorce check it out so day
one after
filing
and I feel so
sad I know I'm going to go through
different emotions but right now I feel
sad um I think the last time I felt a
pain like this was when my mom
died and in a way this is a death you
guys like torture yeah I guess so
yeah I mean if you're comparing your
divorce to death then why did you do it
they're like I don't want to do this but
you why
um of Hope and I look around and I I see
I just want to scream like I see the
Christmas trees that I put up
then all this beautiful home and all my
dreams I had for us I just want to
scream I just want to like run away I
want to get I want to I don't want to
see any of this it hurts you know I
don't want to see
it I know that um this is going to be a
process for me ups and downs and I'm
sure you know probably like Cory smile
like get over it you know but this is my
page to heal and to be brutally honest
heal and overshare overshare she's going
to talk about her dating and stuff about
every piece of this
journey so I barely slept last night
I've got a
migraine my heart's broken
and
uh so much me wishes that he'd be like
I'll change I'll fix this I love you
yeah you can't control your husband look
at we don't want our husbands
controlling us and I hear women say this
over and over again she she has a weak
husband that she wants to exert control
over and he's probably tried for years
to make her happy and can't so I'm sorry
for all the things I said you know you
never deserved it it I'll never yeah so
that's that's simping right there A lot
of times we do deserve to hear the truth
sometimes the truth is Harsh we deserve
to be told no because us women we're
just a bit manipulative we we are and it
men's job is to see through the
and be the head of the household again
I'll I'll pay attention to you I'll I'll
I'll communicate with you I'll lose my
Ang okay so now I'm hearing he's willing
to work on the things you said it's not
going to
change but I guess I'm somebody that
will always have and now this is
allowing her to live in delusion because
she thinks she's right she thinks she's
right she's wrong
because not not always have until the
divorce you will not remarry it is very
unlikely that you will remarry very
unlikely we choose truth over facts and
I'll always have
hope that things could change um and I
guess that's just me being stupid sure
many of you would
say or maybe it's just me trying to see
the good in everybody I don't know what
it is um I'm not weak I don't know why I
became this woman who am
I but this is why is she naked in bed
I'm at today this
morning I'm sad so let me get this clear
she doesn't know what she wants okay one
to 10 this probably this woman probably
was hot at one point she's like a four
now what do you guys think is out in the
dating Market as a single mother
four genuine like what do you think is
on the other side of
this yeah I don't know man she doesn't
know who she is she doesn't know if she
made the right choice or not but she is
the first person to tell her husband how
he should treat her you just can't make
this up this next clip is really
going to show you how needy this woman
really is so I saw a comment I deleted
it but I need to respond to it someone
asked to hear my husband's
side so let me tell you my husband's
side well um he loved me and gave me
everything he had did everything in the
world for me and you know what I have to
tell you though actually to his credit
he did do so much for me except show me
love and respect okay do you see this he
did so much except give me treat me
exactly how I wanted to be treated guys
why do you think you're entitled the
perfect treatment all the time sometimes
we're annoying sometimes we and the
other thing about us women is we
interpret in information like there have
been so many times in my life and I and
I'll say this okay where I have taken
something to be offensive when it was
not intended to be offensive and many
times as women we will overreact to
something said to us when it was not
meant in that way and always in my life
I have never if I've looked back at a
situation I've had situations where I
have regretted the way I behaved and
there have been situations where I was
proud of the way I behave I have always
been more proud of the situations where
I have given someone the benefit of the
doubt because when you get angry you
make assumptions or you assume bad
intent typically it just adds fuel to
the fire it gets worse and attention and
hold me and kiss me and I mean how often
do you guys need I'm sorry maybe I'm
just maybe I'm just a tomboy and I'm not
acting like we don't need that at all we
do but it's like ladies I mean after a
couple kids what do you guys look at me
and and communicate with me and um try
to have a conflict resolution ever
um he he did everything in the world
that money could do or he could
physically do but
emotionally he he's been gone since
month two and I happen to be
pregnant so um what does that even
mean yeah see Heavy make up and that's
very typical of the personality type I'm
dealing with there you have it she even
admitted that her ex-husband did a lot
for her but she still wanted more yeah
yeah we just have this this is why we
have to marry men that say no and I know
ladies men that give us anything
everything we end up hating we end up
hating guys without backbones we end up
hating that makes no sense not give
enough affection to a broken woman she
will always want more because CU all she
really wants is validation at all times
just for existing and the next clip will
show you more proof that a broken woman
knows deep down that she is inadequate
and that is why she need attention all
the time just to feel alive okay so I've
got a business
idea we need to come up with a robot
boyfriend or girlfriend partner whatever
oh they're making those they're making
those for people that are um going
through a divorce
that way you don't feel super lonely and
you can like or or is there like a
service ladies we're so crazy we're
getting replaced of men or women but for
me a be man that I could
buy um to just give me compliments all
day and tell me he loves me and
everything's going to be okay and call
me and check on me and like just build
me the hell up and because I don't
actually
want someone I just want some
affirmation I know that's that's the
problem women don't want the man they
want the attention from the man I mean
you just can't make this up
now so is there we we need to create a
service like this it used to it used to
just be getting married and staying
married K right now this might come out
as a joke but remember that it is the
same thing she said about what was wrong
with her ex-husband this means that it
is in her belief that a man should
compliment and validate her all the
times now before the sweet tears of
regret I will show you one more clip
that will illustrate how much this woman
is confused after filing for divorce she
decided to come back in her ex-husband's
life then decided to leave again by
claiming her so-called abuse her life is
just such a mess check it out hey y'all
um it's
Cory and I'm finally ready I know a lot
lot of you
um were probably cringing that I gave
him another
chance um like where does the a post
wall single mother four have the
audacity to say that she's giving him
another chance I wish I could talk to
this guy look it she will not behave
until you say no and walk away she won't
do it won't do it you can't negotiate
with terrorists guys you can't
sence I spent the past year um
with the divorce filed sitting in the
court and
um doing all the things on all the lists
that he said I should do um and what I
learned is that didn't
stop the abuse what is AB in fact what
is abuse what is it told
that what is I'm experiencing isn't
abuse and I'm making it
up I have no words um an incident
happened a few days
ago where he had an
iPad and he was holding it up saying he
was going to bash my effing face
in so it's never don't believe this I
contacted the Domestic Violence Center
um and we have we are getting a
TPO um
started um and that's about it she
doesn't go to Criminal Court I bet you
she doesn't
head I'm going to be doing a lot of
videos during this process cuz this was
so therapeutic for me before um to get
this out and hopefully my story helps
somebody else I've been in this for 8
years I did believe it was all my fault
cuz that's what I was told um and now
probably was probably was I know it's
not and I know that this it probably was
actually uh abuse this is she's a
narcissist
and
um here we go call me heartless but I do
not believe that this woman was abused
and guys trust me when I say that I do
not encourage abuse in relationships but
you tell me after listening to this
woman talking do you still believe a
word that comes out of her mouth no I
don't believe anything I mean she
changes her mind all the time one minute
she believes that she is the victim and
2 minutes later she believes that she is
actually the problem
she got no mind of her own we are going
to close with this video with a clip of
her crying after getting a temporary
restraining order against her husband
and even at the end she is still not
sure about what she is actually
doing I did
[Laughter]
it I didn't need a four get to like tell
everything
but I did it and it's so evil it's so
evil because these institutions back up
women's delusion and so we really it
really just makes us live in this like
crazy delusion where we do nothing wrong
up for myself I tell the truth only a
little bit of what's going on and I'm
sure I won't get a 12-month one
but I stood up for myself I stood up for
my
daughter you know one day you're kids
will grow up ladies and they talk they
one day your kids grow up and they will
talk and what will they have to say
about the decisions that you made to
never hurt me again because now he's on
noticed yeah I've seen enough guys this
is another crazy lady and you can tell
it's so funny because the women that
like go crazy when they're older it like
wears on their face you just see it like
they get these like crazy eyes she was
bored she wanted to leave um she wanted
the excitement of this up and down
Journey whatever she wants to be the
star of her movie this is a guy that
said yes he didn't know the word no and
he created a monster I was probably
already there let me know what you guys
think in the comments make sure you like
the video on your way out subscribe to
the channel I'll talk to you next
time